your money is going to line Donald
Trump's pockets with a brief temporary
stop in the coffers of the Secret
Service this is a story in plain sight
its corruption and kleptocracy this is
not about policy this is not about the
economy or anything other than we have a
funnel of taxpayer money into Donald
Trump and his family's pockets every
single day and here's how it works the
Secret Service protects Donald Trump
it's part of the Department of Homeland
Security they travel around with Trump
everywhere when Trump stays at his
hotels golf's at his clubs
your taxpayer money which funds DHS and
Secret Service is used for Secret
Service to rent hotels for them to rent
golf carts to drive around protecting
Trump while he golf's and the money is
then just funneled right back into
Donald Trump's pockets because these are
Donald Trump's businesses Eric Trump
once claimed we charged the government a
discount rate that's our costs just to
recoup what it costs us to run the
resort we recently found out that's BS
mar-a-lago is charging 650 per room to
secret service that's more than their
cost you can be sure at Trump Bedminster
Secret Service paid $17,000 to rent a
cottage for a month
even though Trump never spent a night
there as president and I want to go back
to something from Trump's time between
election and inauguration back in 2016
Trump famously held this press
conference standing in front of big
stacks of paper where he said look
here's all the paperwork were taking me
out of my businesses I won't be running
them all of this nonsense and of course
no one got to look at those stacks of
paper in front of Trump but the concept
was laughable because whatever they were
doing unless Trump was actually selling
his interests in those businesses he
knows that these are his businesses he
knows that he and his family make money
off of them there's no way to put in a
blind trust these business entities in
an effective way since Trump knows which
hotels he owns he's aware of where he's
staying when he goes and travels
somewhere the mere idea that Trump was
doing something to eliminate the
conflicts of interest with his
businesses was a joke from day one and
now you and I and all of us are simply
funding it as Trump secret
service protection is lining Trump's own
pockets
we use the term kleptocracy that's what
this is kleptocracy is a government by
those who seek chiefly status and
personal gain at the expense of the
governed we're at the height of
kleptocracy we've got a lifelong grifter
continuing the grift as president the
Republicans don't care they regularly
dine with Trump at his restaurants and
hotels they're supporting it and there's
no accountability on the horizon these
are violations of the Constitution this
violates the emoluments clause when
foreign dignitaries come to the US and
say let's stay at Trump's hotel to
ingratiate ourselves with him but if his
base doesn't care no one's going to do a
thing about it and the big conclusion
the surprising one isn't that a person
who is corrupt their whole life is
continuing to be corrupt as president
that's not surprising the news here is
that when the framers set up checks and
balances they assumed the president
would be a person of substance at the
time they probably have said a man of
substance someone who had never flout
all the rules the way Donald Trump is
doing the checks and balances aren't
strong enough because the framers never
imagined a president would come along
and get himself elected who would then
exploit every aspect of those checks and
balances Donald Trump if he's done
anything positive he has exposed the
cracks in the system maybe we should be
grateful I guess as long as we fix it
and get him the hell out I'm not
currently willing to bet that that's the
most likely outcome but we will see come
November I want to give a quick shout
out to one of our sponsors VIN Charo
watches they're giving my audience 15%
off your entire order when you go to
david pakman.com slash watch maybe you
don't usually wear a watch and you've
been thinking about looking for one to
elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have check out VIN Charo it's an
American company all of their watches
are built in small batches from high-end
materials they look amazing and they
look like something you'd spend a lot of
money on but ever even Cheryl watch
ranges from a hundred and fifty to three
hundred dollars I went on their website
and picked out
the Kairos in white and silver really
love the look the combination of the
white face and the beige band really
love this one they also sent me the
Kairos limited release gold reserve set
totally different style this one would
make a fantastic gift for a couple
people I can think of in my family
anytime you see me wearing a watch on
the show I'm wearing a Ventura watch go
through their collection I know you'll
find something you like and you'll get
15% off when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch